bonsoir monsieur duclos on vient de
faire le tour ça s'aggrave et hansen
landes sont en fait assez s'il ne faut
pas en faire plus notamment du côté de
t'avoir pour lutter contre la
propagation
bonsoir nouri bonsoir à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent et la question est tout à
fait légitime
on sait très bien la situation est grave
à la situation est urgente et c'est pour
ça que tout ce qui a été fait au cours
des dernières semaines doit absolument
renforcer
moi je me réjouis évidemment de voir les
mesures qui sont prises à l'échelle du
canada
en fonction des directives et des
conseils des informations fournies par
l' agence santé publique du canada en
fonction évidemment des conditions
locales de chacune des provinces est en
fait de chacune des municipalités
est ce que vous l'avez échappé notamment
aux frontières en corbières les gens qui
reviennent de voyage et qui respecte des
mesures de d'isolement de confinement
volontaire ou obligatoire selon
l'origine
10 qui a pas de contrôle et cela même le
québec aujourd'hui qui annonce envoyée
dans les aéroport au québec des gens
pour informer les voyageurs de la
responsabilité civique carrément pour
qu'ils acceptent d'isolement il ya des
gens qui vous réclame des mesures plus
corsé plus draconiennes aux frontières
bon retour aux choses rapidement
la province et qui dirait qu'ils sont
très claires la loi sur la quarantaine
s'applique à tous les passagers qu'ils
soient canadiens ou étrangers
lorsque les passagers ressent des
symptômes pense avoir été en contact ou
ont été en contact avec quelqu'un qui
souffre du virus
lorsque ces gens viennent de pays à
risque ils doivent nécessairement révélé
à l'agent doit nier cette information et
faire en sorte qu'ils soient isolés
durant au moins deux semaines
la deuxième chose c'est que évidemment
c'est le duo vont devoir être renforcée
au cours des prochains jours
monsieur trudeau aura une annonce
importante à faire demain mais ce
renforcement s'inscrit dans un contexte
mondial qui est encore plus
problématique que la situation que nous
avons au canada et je dois dire que
cette situation même si elle est
évidemment préoccupante est de loin plus
enviable que celle qui ont envie dans
d'autres pays et la troisième chose
c'est que cet exercice et vira se
combine aux exercices tout aussi
important de santé publique
lorsque les gens à madame tan qui l'a la
directrice de l'agencé de santé publique
aujourd'hui le disais pour la première
fois lorsque les gens peu importe d'où
ils viennent peu importe qu'ils aient pu
rencontrer à l'étranger lorsque les
rushs des gens reviennent du canada on
s'attend maintenant à ce qu'il soit
automatiquement en période d isolation
pour au moins deux semaines ses rivaux
qu'il avance la quarantaine écouter les
témoignages qu'on d'as et c'est pas dans
le même sens mon enfant d'abord les gens
la connaissent pas la loi sur la
quarantaine ne le serait ignorer la loi
mais dans les faits c'est bien autre
chose on voit toute la confusion qui
règne
ils le sont la liste des pays à risque
est très court les gens ne sont pas
interrogées encore hier avant hier alors
que la situation s'aggrave le québec a
réagi rapidement et ont pour plusieurs
le québec est un modèle à la fois de
communication et de prise en compte la
gravité actuelle est aussi probable avec
tu avec ce fameux modèle de modélisation
donc ne vaut-il pas mieux agir
puis demain visite monsieur trudeau va
annoncer quelque chose demain mais ce
qui est pas déjà trop tard
non mais écoutez cette urgence et les
elle est présente et elle est totalement
assumée depuis déjà plusieurs semaines
ça fait déjà évident à plusieurs
semaines que des mesures de contrôles
accrus ont été appliquées aux frontières
quand je parle d' obligations s'est pas
seulement l'obligation des passagers
étrangers surtout sur l'obligation des
douaniers de ils ont le pouvoir et aussi
le devoir d'imposer des mesures de
l'information évidemment mais et on
comprend que tout n'est pas parfait et
c'est pour ça que les les ressources et
les temps et les personnes humaines des
employés qui vont devoir être mis à
disposition de ces services vont
s'accroître encore davantage au cours
des prochains jours parce que cette
crise s'intensifie rapidement
messapresse un peu les scénarios qui
sont sur la table parce que le québec
prend acte des scénarios probables et
déjà fermé écoles fermées lieux publics
par des regroupements alors que les
voyageurs étrangers qui arrivent ici
peuvent soit mentir peuvent se promener
librement sont pas en isolement
il échappe à la loi et à chapeau
contrôle alors que les québécois eux
mêmes les canadiens eux doivent
respecter des consignes c'est comme deux
poids deux mesures sur une
responsabilité partagée effectivement
tout le monde ont la responsabilité de
respecter la loi c'est vrai pour ceux
qui n'ont pas voyagé à l'extérieur du
pays c'est vrai aussi faux ce et c'est
en grande partie des canadiens qui
reviennent de l'étranger
chacun doit respecter la loi la loi sur
la cam en terre en particulier pour ceux
qui reviennent de l'étranger
il semble que les ressources soient pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'il faut faire
le ministre blais requis responsables de
sécurité publique a annoncé aujourd'hui
que ces mesures allaient renforcer
encore davantage c'est pas juste un bout
de vie de d'informer les gens de la loi
c'est aussi de mettre les ressources
nécessaires pour que cette loi soit
respectée on a évité toute spéciale sur
le plateau si la conseillère en chef
cancer signe scientifique en chef du
canada qui dans le fond la chef
d'orchestre de tout ce qu'ils doivent
faire en matière de recherche
scientifique et tout ça je vais poser
tout à l'heure la question sur la
fermeture des frontières il existe
effectivement des études qui montrent
que la fermeture des frontières ça peut
retarder d'ailleurs le président 30 à
qui on reproche bien des choses se vante
lui d'avoir
fermer la frontière avec la chine big c
a bloqué la cage il ya d'autres
problèmes aux états unis dès lundi même
chose va fermer à l'europe parce qu'il
ya des problèmes de dépistage et tout ça
mais quand même
alors ça sans s'inspirer nécessairement
de monsieur curtis homme qu'il existait
que le grondement et au fait qu'il
existe des études qui montrent que si
une fermeture des frontières
ça peut être comme un mur ça peut
stopper est vraiment retarder la
propagation de la maladie d'autant qu'on
n'est pas nécessairement prêts un
système de santé de l'assumer cette
propagation
deux exemples contrastées ap 2 le
premier celui de l'italie où on a
observé dans a fait après le canada le
premier cas et on a fermé les frontières
et vous savez maintenant l'italie a non
seulement le plus haut taux de 2 cas
d'infection ou en europe et où on
retrouve aussi le plus grand nombre de
morts le deuxième cas c'est les états
unis où on a ignoré durant tron l'autre
est longtemps et trop longtemps
l'importance de travailler en santé
communautaire pour faire ce qu'on fait
bien au québec et au canada c'est à dire
de l'identifier et d'accompagner et
d'isoler les gens qui ont des symptômes
de virus plutôt que de blâmer les
étrangers et les autres pays alors c'est
ce processus qui fonctionne bien au
canada
au canada on a des agents de santé
publique qui font qu'ils travaillent
fort pour suivre les gens pour les
accompagner durant la période
d'isolement qu'il doive subir le temps
qu'ils ont ce virus
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup on
espère une communication quotidien de la
part du gouvernement
merci beaucoup merci au revoir